let's go next to let's try the seven
seven four area code sticking again
potentially with Massachusetts who's
calling today from seven seven four hi
this me yes it is hi David I'm Trevor
from Worcester Trevor what's going on so
I just wanted to ask you about Biden's
environmental plan again he put a bunch
of different cool not cool but very
progressive pieces into his policy like
I was saying the environmental and
climate division in the DOJ and
overhauling the EPA external civil
rights compliance office and creating a
national crisis strategy and all that
stuff but what did Biden in Europe
ending bleep out of his plan that maybe
the progressives in his unity group
wanted into the plan that he left out
you know you you'd have to ask them I've
only looked at a bulleted summary so far
I've not read through all of it but
certainly the Biden plan is not the
green New Deal the Biden plan is you
know what I found good about the Biden
plan in terms of the summaries that I've
read is that he's doing what he promised
to do in other words months ago Joe
Biden said I support the green New Deal
as a framework with which I will build a
plan and we'll listen to what the green
New Deal says and consider other voices
and a lot of people said I don't believe
it I don't believe it I don't believe it
and the Biden plan integrates some of
the milestones and guidelines of the
green New Deal into a plan that to be
clear is not the green New Deal but what
I'm pleased by is that first of all I
mean listen again Biden is not an ultra
progressive if Biden gets to do what
he's proposing it will be the most
progressive environmental plan in the
history of the United States now you're
gonna have people who come out and say
he'll never get it done well that's not
unique to Biden no president gets
everything done that they say they want
to do you'll hear people come out and
say Biden doesn't really believe this
stuff he's only saying it because he
thinks it will help him politically you
can say that about any candidate and to
some degree it's always true but the
idea that Biden is particularly
dishonest about what you
I've seen no evidence for so listen if I
do a full review I could come back to
you and say here's the five things that
aren't in it that should be but overall
I like that Biden has stuck to his word
of using the green New Deal as a
framework for putting together a plan
I'm pleased with it hello Trevor from
I'm sorry I missed that last part I'm
sorry I'm pleased overall that Joe Biden
has stuck to his word and used the green
New Deal as a framework for his plan
yeah I agree completely that the green
New Deal is a great framework it should
be what we have but this is definitely a
great alternative my second question
really quickly would be that do we need
the electoral college in order or rather
in order to implement rank-choice voting
into our voting system do we need the
electoral college in or can we should we
get rid of it in order to implement
rank-choice voting you can do it's
really two separate things I mean listen
if you go to national popular vote you
eliminate electors per state and you can
tally the national popular vote as
first-past-the-post or rank choice
voting single transferable vote etc
that'd be one path the other path is you
keep the electoral college but at the
individual state level the elections are
held using a ranked choice or
alternative voting system so these a lot
of people talk about doing both together
obviously it's incredibly unlikely that
you're going to get both together
nationally at the exact same time but
they don't have to both be done together
okay awesome thanks for answering my
questions all right Trevor thank you so
much for the phone call I very much
appreciate it